Karen Strode was born sometime in the early
1980s.
This is evident based on the fact that in
2018, Karen appears to be in her late 30s
or early 40s, and this is further backed up
by the fact that she has a teenage daughter
who was born in 2000 or 2001.
It is unclear who Karen’s father could have
been, but Karen is the daughter of Laurie
Strode.
…Not that daughter.
That’s Jamie Lloyd, Laurie’s daughter
in a different timeline.
Think of it as an alternate reality.
There’s also a timeline where Laurie has
a son instead of a daughter.
But in this timeline, it’s just Karen.
But Karen and Jamie do share similarities.
Much like Jamie, she would eventually succumb
to the attacks of Michael Myers, despite her
mother’s excessive efforts to protect her.
To learn more about Karen, how Laurie’s
trauma was passed down to her, how she’s
covertly connected to Jamie Lloyd, and why
the writers changed her character to avoid
controversy, stick around to the end of this
video.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History.
In today’s lesson, we are taking a deeper
look at the intergenerational trauma passed
down through the Strode family.
If you’ve seen other Horror History episodes
on characters from the Halloween franchise,
then you’re likely familiar with the Halloween
Express, a train map I came up with as an
analogy to explain the timeline.
Each route is an alternate timeline, and each
stop is a different Halloween movie.
Karen appears in the 40 Year Timeline, which
follows the original Halloween with Halloween
(2018), Halloween Kills, and then continues
on without Karen in Halloween Ends.
For her first appearance in Halloween (2018),
writers were initially planning to name her
Jamie, as a tribute to her counterpart from
the original timeline.
In a way this makes sense, because both timelines
start with the same Laurie Strode.
So if Laurie liked that name in the original
timeline, then I don’t see any reason she
wouldn’t like it in this one.
Jamie and Karen would have been born around
the same time in their respective continuities,
only a couple years after the timeline split
in 1978.
However, they probably didn’t want to confuse
casual audiences into thinking that this was
Jamie, so the name was changed.
To..
Shanah Nelson?
And then, to Karen Nelson.
This was before the Karen meme took off, otherwise,
I’m sure they would have gone with Shanah.
Or something else.
Actually, if they called her Shanah, then
when they showed her old gun at the end of
Halloween (2018), the initials would have
been SS, and it would have looked like some
Nazi thing.
Maybe it’s best that they just switched
it to Karen.
Karen was raised in what can only be described
as “army boot-camp” like conditions.
Laurie kept her daughter in a very sheltered
and strict home life and started giving her
some version of combat training, starting
when Karen was only eight years old.
– I learned how to shoot a gun when I was
eight.
I learned how to fight.
I had nightmares about the basement.
– To better understand why Laurie put her own
daughter through this instead of doing normal
80s kid stuff like riding bikes, and…
I don’t know, basically just riding bikes,
and riding bikes.
OH DID I MENTION RIDING BIKES?
…we’re going to have to take it back to
that infamous Halloween night in 1978.
(haunting music)
In the original 1978 Halloween, Laurie started
out as a relatively happy and normal teenage girl.
She was considered a good student, she would
talk about crushes with her friends and stow
away her babysitting money, which probably
came in handy when she popped one out before
finishing college.
But on Halloween night in 1978, when all of
Laurie’s friends are murdered by a man in
a William Shatner mask, she is left completely
traumatized.
So much so that when some guy in a trenchcoat
who she's never seen before shows up with
a gun, she doesn’t even question it.
– Was the boogeyman?
– [Zac] The murder of her friends and subsequent attempt
on her own life, understandably, change Laurie
forever.
At some point in her adulthood, she buys a
house on a plot of land at the edge of Haddonfield,
almost completely isolated from others.
She turns it into her own private bunker and
trap for Michael Myers.
For most of Karen’s childhood, this is where
she was raised.
– [Ray] What’s this?
–  [Karen] It’s my childhood.
– Laurie is suffering from Post Traumatic Stress
Disorder.
It’s not uncommon for parents suffering
from PTSD to pass down what is referred to
as intergenerational trauma.
According to a study by Psychiatric Times:
patients with parents suffering with PTSD
often describe damaged, preoccupied parents
who are emotionally limited.
Symptoms in parents such as traumatic reliving,
emotional numbing and dissociative phenomena
do not help a child develop a reasonable sense
of safety and predictability in the world.
This would absolutely apply to Karen, as Laurie’s
trauma from the attack left her unable to
be emotionally available for Karen as a parent.
Even the interactions they share as adults,
give a pretty clear indication of how Laurie
would have interacted with her as a child:
– [Laurie] You have no security system, Karen.
Your side window was wide open.
Sometimes I can’t tell the difference between
your stupidity and your ignorance.
– As stated in the intro, it is unclear who
Karen’s father was.
When Laurie is interviewed by a pair of investigative
journalists, she mentions that she went through
two divorces but never specifies if either
of her ex-husbands were Karen’s Dad.
My guess is: no.
When we see Karen’s old gun, it’s engraved
with the letters KS.
She has never been shown to be a Kansas fan,
so the assumption is that this stands for
Karen Strode.
If she has her mother’s last name, she was
probably born out of wedlock.
Sure, maybe the father’s last name also
started with ‘S’.
We don’t know.
Karen never mentions ever having any kind
of father figure.
The only men that we know were in Laurie’s
life at the time are Frank Hawkins, who stated
that he never made it past first base with
Laurie and Ben Tramer, who liked Laurie, but
Laurie still has a crush on him when she’s old enough
to go to a bar, so I’m guessing he’s not
the absent father.
– [Hawkins] …But I knew you were sweet for Ben Tramer.
– [Zac] Either way, Karen was raised by a single mother,
which is already not a good thing, and that
single mother was suffering from PTSD, meaning that
Karen was not afforded with any kind of stability
and had to cope with the effects of her mother’s
trauma alone.
While Laurie may have thought she was protecting
her daughter by teaching her to fight back
against Michael, her actions would have extreme
consequences.
When Karen was twelve years old, the Strode
household was visited by social services who
deemed Laurie unfit to be a mother.
Karen was placed into the foster care system
for the rest of her childhood.
– [Reporter] How long until you regained custody?
– I didn’t.
– In foster care, Karen learned to cope with
the damage that her mother instilled by being
overly optimistic and refusing to see the
world as a “scary” place like Laurie does.
There may have been a little bit of an over-correction
on the part of her new caregivers, causing
her to be a little too trusting of mankind,
but for the most part, it seems they did a
great job with her, because as an adult she
seems integrated as a productive and generally
problem-free member of society.
Karen eventually meets and marries a man named
Ray Nelson.
Ray is the opposite of Laurie in every way.
Where Laurie is tough and over-prepared, Ray
is soft and doesn’t overthink things.
In fact, at times, it seems like he hardly
thinks at all.
– Daww man! I got peanut butter on my penis.
– [Zac] At a very young age, maybe 22 at the oldest,
Karen becomes pregnant with a daughter, and
the addition of the newest member of the family,
has an unintended side effect.
Karen’s mother would be coming back into
the picture.
(impact)
(spooky music)
Karen and Ray Nelson gave birth to a daughter
in 2000 or 2001 and named her Allyson.
Karen tries to raise Allyson completely different
from how Laurie raised her.
Where Laurie showed very little interest in
Karen as a person, Karen goes out of her way
to be actively engaged in Allyson’s life.
She insists on coming to Allyson’s induction
into the National Honor Society, tells her
she’s excited to meet her boyfriend and,
even though Karen avoids celebrating Halloween
due to the fact that the anniversary of the
babysitter murders was the day her mother
was consistently at her craziest, she gives
encouragement when Allyson shares that she’s
planning on attending the Halloween dance.
Which is pretty significant, since Karen has
grown to hate Halloween so much that she wears
a Christmas sweater on the big day.
Allyson’s friend at one point suggests
ignoring the holiday altogether, which seems
to be what Karen is going for.
– [Vicky] If I were you guys, I wouldn't celebrate,
either.
I would just put up a Christmas tree instead.
– If I lived in Haddonfield, Michael Myers would
be the least of her worries, because she'd
have to answer -- to me.
But the poor choice of attire is further proof
of Karen’s refusal to follow in Laurie’s footsteps.
Laurie tried to cope with Halloween by preparing
to fight, Karen copes by finding something
that comforts her.
At this point, there are already parallels
we can draw between Karen and Jamie.
Jamie also didn’t have much interest in
celebrating, or dressing up for Halloween,
at least at first, she eventually changes
her mind so she can try to fit in with her
classmates.
In Halloween (2018) we see Laurie trying to
prepare young Karen for an encounter with
Michael Myers, which she says gives her nightmares.
In Halloween 4: The Return of Michael Myers,
we also see Jamie having nightmares about
The Boogeyman, implying that at the very least,
Laurie did teach her about her family’s
history with evil.
Despite Karen’s best efforts, Laurie’s
trauma still trickles down to Allyson.
Allyson feels hurt by Karen’s always active
attempts to keep Laurie away and keeps prodding
to find out if her Mom has invited Laurie
to her Honors celebration dinner.
Karen lies to her, and states that she did
ask, but that Laurie would not be able to
make it.
Allyson is particularly hurt because she knows
her mother is lying.
But Karen sees this as a way of protecting
her, and we soon see why.
Allyson goes around Karen and invites her
Grandmother anyway.
When Laurie arrives, Karen’s lie is revealed.
However, the issue is immediately put to rest
by Laurie’s own erratic behavior.
She shows up drinking and ranting in a way
that makes her look insane.
Karen responds by setting boundaries and offering
suggestions, such as “going for a walk”
or “hitting the reset button and starting
over” that seem like something one might
learn in therapy or even implement as a therapist.
– [Laurie] I saw him. The Shape.
– Mom...
– I didn't know what to do.
– I think maybe this is a little bit too much
for you, huh?
Why don’t we go for a walk, alright?
You said you were going to try to put the
past behind you.
Okay?
Are you going to try to do that?
That’s what you said you wanted to do.
– [Laurie] I can’t.
– Mom, look at me.
– There is a specific reason that Karen communicates
this way.
In addition to the therapy that we can safely
assume Karen has gone through, Karen may actually
be a therapist herself, based on the way she
tells Allyson that she “rescheduled her
last session” so that she can attend Allyson’s
induction into the National Honor Society.
I mean, she could be a personal trainer, or
a prostitute I guess, but she just doesn’t
look the part.
In the original script, she’s actually described
as a “children’s psychologist”; it’s
not canon in the movie, but I’m kind of
willing to go with that.
It makes sense that Karen would be inspired
to choose a profession where she could help
kids that were going through what she went
though.
However, despite Karen making it very clear
how bad her childhood was, and obviously choosing
not to pursue a relationship with her Mom,
Laurie does not regret how she chose to raise
Karen.
She still feels it necessary to do what she
considers protecting her by breaking into
her house to point out the lacking security
system.
It reminds me of those guys on cop shows who
get caught stealing a car, and try to say
they were in the process of returning it…
but like if they were actually telling the
truth.
– I was just gonna take the car to the police
station.
– Once again, Karen uses the tools she has learned
through therapy to navigate this unwanted
interaction with her Mom, stating that Laurie
“needs to get help” and that she is “not
welcome in this house until she gets it.”
Also, Ray makes a feeble and embarrassing
attempt to defend Karen.
– Hey Laurie, this is my home and I can take care
of my own family, all right?
I know jutjitsu-
– [Zac] Ray thinks he’s Busta Rhymes out here.
Can’t blame Laurie for not trusting Ray
with anyone’s safety.
I can understand Karen’s desire to start
a family that’s going to be different from
her situation growing up, but really?
This guy?
It comes as no surprise that Ray is not able
to get Laurie to leave and it’s Karen who
has to intervene, insisting that the world
is not a “dark and evil place.”
It’s 2018, Karen.
If only you stuck around a couple more years.
Unfortunately for Karen, all of Laurie’s
fears were about to come true and no amount
of positive thinking or Christmas sweaters
would be able to prevent the force that is
Michael Myers.
As news of his escape spreads through Haddonfield,
Laurie and Deputy Hawkins are the first to
take it seriously and spring into action.
Hawkins agrees that Michael is likely after
Laurie and her family and assists her in convincing
Karen to take shelter at Laurie’s house.
However, Allyson is not with Karen, and they
can’t reach her phone, making it impossible
to track down Allyson’s current whereabouts.
Left with little choice, Karen and Ray leave
for Laurie’s house, leaving messages for
Allyson to meet them there.
When they arrive, Karen is faced with reminders
of all the past trauma she had tried so hard
to leave behind.
The trap they prepare for Michael in the basement
brings up twisted memories of Karen’s nightmarish
experiences working down there as a girl.
Despite her feelings about how her childhood
transpired, it’s clear that her training
made her an expert on using a gun.
– [Laurie] You never wanted to listen to
me when I spoke of that night.
And this is why.
I’ve been preparing for this for a long
time.
– It doesn’t take long for Michael to find
them, and I’m sure no one will be shocked
to know that Ray is the first to be killed.
(Ray screams)
Karen hides in the basement alone when Michael
breaks in, and she hears her mother’s battle
with the boogeyman rage on all throughout
the house above her.
It’s during this struggle, that Allyson,
after having her own traumatic night, finds
her way in as well.
Karen calls her downstairs and they both hide
in the basement.
But Michael is able to find the secret entrance,
and muscle the kitchen island that’s blocking
it out of the way.
With nothing standing between her and her
family’s worst nightmare, Karen begs and
pleads for Laurie to find them, crying that
she can’t do it by herself, and Michael,
realizing he has a trapped victim, appears
in the stairway.
But Karen is only acting.
– Gotcha.
– Despite her attempts to put her childhood
combat training behind her, it is still engrained
in her memory, like remembering how to ride
a bike.
Or I guess in her case *instead* of learning
how to ride a bike, because she’s the one
80s kid that didn’t do that.
Seeing the horror from Haddonfield first hand
causes Karen to completely drop her “world
is not a dark and evil place” attitude,
and from that point forward, she becomes just
as vicious as her mother.
Allyson and Karen just barely escape Michael’s
grasp as they rush up the stairs and it’s
Karen who activates the bars that lock Michael
into the basement tomb, which is now filling
up with gas.
Laurie throws in a flare which starts a huge
fire.
The entire house has been designed as a trap,
so that if this day ever should come, Michael
would burn down with it.
We see a doll house in Karen’s old room
go up in flames, which represents Karen’s
childhood.
Karen always wanted to be a normal kid, but
Laurie wanted to train her for combat.
The image represents the trade-off Karen was
forced to make all those years ago -- she’s
giving up her normal childhood in exchange
for safety as an adult.
The three generations of women are able to
flee the house and flag down a ride from a
couple of Illinois boys, thinking that they
have successfully killed Michael Myers and
ended the terror that has hung over their
town for the last 40 years.
However, this hope would soon be extinguished.
(impact)
(spooky music)
When Laurie, Allyson and Karen, get to the
hospital, Laurie is rushed into emergency
surgery, leaving Karen and Allyson to cope
with the loss of Ray.
Karen looks at her blood soaked hands and
tries to wash the gory stains from her wedding
ring, signifying that she’ll never be able
to return to the optimistic life and worldview
that she had worked so hard to build with
her husband.
As Karen and Allyson are questioned by police,
they both learn that Michael survived and escaped.
Allyson wants to join her boyfriend and the
town mob to go look for Michael and kill him,
while Karen is certain that he will be coming
to the hospital, and that they should stick
close to Laurie and protect her.
She later goes into her Mom’s room as she’s
waking up, and discovers a note left behind
by Allyson, explaining that she’s joined
the anti Michael mob, and that it is her love
for her family that is driving her to hunt
him down, not unlike Laurie.
I can only imagine how crushing that was for
her.
She spent her whole parenthood trying to give
Allyson a better life, only to see her become
a fighter, just like her Grandmother, when
it’s most critical for them to stick together.
Despite this, she does a really impressive
job of keeping it together in order to prevent
Laurie from finding out that Michael survived.
– She probably just needed some fresh
air.
– The goal is to keep Laurie in bed, so she
can continue to heal, and this is the second
time Karen has manipulated her emotions to
trick someone; the first being when she acted
like a helpless victim at the foot of the
basement stairs.
She leaves her mom alone to get some rest,
at which point she runs into Tommy Doyle,
and only wants to hear one thing from him.
– Where’s my daughter?
– But even after finding out, she stays at the
hospital, because she really seems to believe
that Michael is after Laurie, whereas Allyson
believes Michael just wants to kill whatever
is in his path.
This divide could be explained by the fact
that Allyson sees that Dr. Sartain was the
one to bring Michael and Laurie together,
and Karen doesn’t know about that.
She’s been told all her life that Michael
is going to come for them, and from her point
of view, hiding in the basement, that’s
exactly what happened.
And to be fair, if this were any other Halloween
movie, she would have been right.
She watches as Tommy riles up the mob, and
her reaction, to me, says: “they have no
idea what they’re in for.”
She does her best to stop Tommy from barging
into Laurie's room and revealing that Michael
Myers is still alive, but he spills the beans
anyway.
Karen tries to justify her lie by saying it
was for her Mom’s safety, which is honestly fair.
I think it’s one of the few justified lies,
just because it’s a situation where telling
the truth would more than likely put Laurie
directly in harm's way when she needs to focus
on healing.
It seems Karen is always willing to bend the
truth to protect those closest to her, as
we saw when she lied to Allyson about inviting
her Grandmother to dinner.
She insists that, despite what Laurie may
think, all of her preparation was for nothing,
yet, Laurie still firmly disagrees and hilariously
drugs herself up with painkillers.
– AHHH!!!!!!!
–  What the hell did I just witness?
– The two basically get into a big fight, which
culminates with this:
– STOP!
I am not gonna let anything happen to you.
– Karen has now unsuccessfully begged both her
daughter and mother to stay with her where
it’s safe, which is another similarity that
she shares with Jamie Lloyd.
In Halloween 5, Jamie has a vision of danger
at the Halloween party her friend Tina is
going to, but nobody will take her seriously,
and Tina goes to the party anyway.
It is not too long after this that the angry
mob finds another escaped mental patient named
Mr. Tivoli and they mistake him for Michael
Myers.
Laurie is the first to realize it’s not
Michael, but she gets injured in the stampede,
so Karen takes it upon herself to try to protect
the man, but despite her best efforts, she’s
unable to save his life.
Back in the hospital room, Hawkins informs
Laurie and Karen about what I was talking
about earlier: the fact that Doctor Sartain
was the one to bring Michael to Laurie earlier
that evening.
This revelation makes Karen realize that if
Michael isn’t targeting Laurie, then her
daughter is in danger of encountering him
out on the streets of Haddonfield.
She gets Tommy to lend her his car and they
devise a plan to lure Michael out into another trap.
Thanks to Deputy Hawkins’s story, she deduces
that he’s probably headed back home, which
is likely where Allyson and the others will
be to try to hunt him.
–  Did you know that when he was
a little boy, he used to stand in his sister’s
bedroom and stare out the window?
… Maybe he wasn’t looking out.
Maybe he was looking in.
At his reflection.
At himself.
– She wastes no time getting there.
Allyson had been traveling with her boyfriend,
Cameron, and Cameron’s dad Lonnie Elam,
so when she saw Lonnie’s empty car outside
the Myers house, she must have feared for
the worst.
She grabbed a pitchfork from the Halloween
decorations on the porch, and lucky for her,
this was a real pitchfork.
And it’s ****ing massive.
She shows up just in the nick of time, as
Michael is about to attack Allyson.
Karen pulls his mask off, just like Laurie
did when he attacked her all those years ago;
like mother, like daughter.
And just like he was four decades earlier,
Michael is transfixed by the mask when it
is taken from him.
I imagine that Karen knows this because Laurie
taught her everything she knew about Michael
Myers, based on her experiences that night,
and made sure that she didn't forget a thing.
So Karen uses the mask to lure him outside,
drawing his attention away from the injured
Allyson.
This scene has got to be the biggest Jamie
Lloyd connection of them all.
Jamie, like Karen, will do anything to protect
her kid.
In Halloween: The Curse of Michael Myers,
Jamie gives birth to a son and uses a similar
tactic to protect him from the Boogeyman.
She hides him in a cabinet and runs away with
a bundle of blankets, thereby tricking Michael
into following her as far away as possible
before she finally succumbs to him, and Michael
is bamboozled upon finding the empty blankets.
That’s basically what Karen is doing here,
luring Michael out away from her vulnerable
daughter.
It’s also an important character development
moment for her.
All night, she’s tried to protect the innocent
people around her: such as her husband, Mr.
Tivoli, heck, even the town of Haddonfield
itself, but she hadn’t found any success
in saving anybody.
With her daughter’s life on the line, she
wasn’t going to settle for being too little
or too late.
Michael gives chase, but instead of sacrificing
herself at the end, like Jamie did, she leads
him into a trap where Tommy Doyle and the
angry mob are waiting.
The sheer numbers of the mob are able to beat
him down, and before going back to be with
her daughter, Karen gets one good knife shot
into Michael’s upper back.
She reunites with Allyson and tries to comfort
her, then as she gets up to give the paramedics
some space, she looks up at Michael’s window,
perhaps remembering Frank Hawkins’s story,
and she sees a strange vision of the child
Michael Myers in his clown costume staring
out over Haddonfield.
This moment is another that she shares with
her original timeline counterpart, because
in Halloween 4: The Return of Michael Myers,
Jamie looks into a mirror and sees child Michael
staring back at her with the same emotionless
expression.
This is reflective of Frank’s earlier words,
“Maybe he wasn’t looking out.
Maybe he was looking in.
At his reflection.
At himself.”
Karen heads upstairs to see for herself what
Michael might have been looking at, but instead
of seeing her own reflection, she sees Michael’s.
He appears behind her and this time, with
no support network around to help her, he
takes the knife and finishes her off, the
very last parallel she shares with Jamie Lloyd,
who was also met with a grisly death at the
hands of Haddonfield’s most feared resident.
I’ve got more episodes lined up for other
40 Year Timeline characters, so let me know
who else you’d like to see covered here
on Horror History and remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell and make sure you select ALL notifications.
Please. Please!
I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.